65 communes labellisées dans les
yvelines en 2019 le département est
d'ailleurs le seul à avoir la
distinction de département fleuri d'île
de france engagée depuis 45 ans une aide
les communes à accéder à leur première
fleur avec un système de pétales avant
de se présenter à la région nous
accompagnons les communes
progressivement en les récompensant au
fur et à mesure de leur progression et
au cinquième pétales nous estimons que
la ville ou le village est prêt à être
présenté au jury régional pour recevoir
sa première fleur mais par contre on
manque un petit peu de communes rurales
les communes rurales sont trop timide
trop timoré alors qu'elles font parfois
des choses extraordinaires avec très peu
de moyens des communes rurales qui ne
sont que 21% à participer à ce label
et parmi elles vont en ville de gaillard
commune de 620 habitants qui vient
justement d'obtenir son cinquième est
allée sera ainsi présenté au jury
régional
en 2020 le fruit d'un travail créatif
pour ma créer un jardin potager un
verger en fait des endroits sympathiques
où les gens puissent venir
ils se rencontrent et quoi bien sûr plus
que les pétales le département se
démarque par ses trophées spéciaux pour
continuer d'encourager la dynamique des
villes et villages déjà fleuri la
commune de coignières de fleurs au
compteur a remporté les trophées coeur
de ville et sa mère et fleurie émaillage
sans trottoirs et pieds de murs fleuris
la récompense d'une équipe d'une
quinzaine de personnes ça permet
vraiment de de relever des défis en
permanence et ce qui permet d'avancer ça
c'est certain c'est vraiment une
incitation à toujours faire mieux 113
commune yvelinoise sont inscrits dans le
dispositif villes et villages fleuris
pour la saison 2001 les inscriptions
label et au trophée du département
s'ouvriront en avril mais pour des
visites du jury tout l'été